yeah hello welcome to a new video this
is some new video in the e4 e5
repertoire series um I'm not quite sure
I think it's part 6 yeah we've come to
the four Knights game which yes very
yeah very fittingly named because the
four Knights get into play at the
beginning of the game and this video
will be about all lines
besides deform in the four Knights game
position here default will get a
separate video of maybe I will do that
together with the scotch game because it
yeah easily can transpose and it's quite
similar to the Scotch also called the
Scotch for Knights here so will do any
other moves and they're quite a couple
the most common move besides d4 years
Bishop b5 this one but let's um go with
the rarer moves first a move that is
sometimes played iation is g3 and this
is quite similar to the whoops I've got
this damn it again come on ok g3 and
this is quite similar to the Vienna game
with g3 just to show this year and in
this position we had d5 takes Knight
takes takes here not c6 Knight f3 as the
mainline and then I had should be 7 but
black can also play Bishop c5 for Bishop
d6 or Musa fine in the four Knights it
is actually quite similar it can and
usually does transpose so we have g3
here and then d5 it takes on d5 Knight
and Bishop g2 takes on c3 Bishop d7 and
we just transposed on as mentioned
before p6 or Bishop c5 also very much
okay for black so this is transmission
transposition but like also has got some
interesting alternatives in this move
order one move here which was suggested
by german grand master yang Gustav saman
his before you five repertoire DVD it's
an ID 4 which is quite funny looking
move it's sort of a yeah Belgrade gambit
we'll come to that later from blacks
perspective um it's quite similar to
this this opening the idea at least and
it seems to me that as he is suggested
on the DVD that this move is also very
good and leads to little needs to find
prey for black I won't go into details
here but if you want some alternatives
this is possible also I'd like to
mention a really shocking move here
black can also play in this position the
absolutely amazing move Knight takes e4
sacrificing a piece and will come later
just in a few seconds - to align for
white which is quite similar to this
idea the ideas of wide recaptures black
plays d5 and in this position white
would like to play Knight G 3 but he
cannot because on G 3 does upon so he
goes to C 3 and then DeForest played and
if white now tries to secure his Knight
let's say he returns it all the way to
to b1 then black pushes further and get
some pretty nice compensation for this
piece it's I know it's hard to believe
it but this is actually playable for
black okay I don't want to spend half an
hour to to demonstrate why this is
playable I just want to mention if he
looks for some
shocking move to really a surprise the
opponent you can take on e form but only
if you study this independently from
this presentation showing it would be
just too much and also as I said a d5 is
a really simple way to get a decent
position mentioning this idea of yeah
strange night sacrifice in this position
actually the really amazing move Knight
takes e5 is a possibility the so called
Helloween gambit I'm not quite sure when
the name comes from yeah it's quite
quite cool that this move is yeah even
worth to look at but it is in fact
Knight takes d4 and now black has more
than one way to get a good position but
it took some time to figure that out
really by analysts um also I'd show I
showed them both just to to give a
choice um a simple solution is 96
just drop the knight back then d5 and in
this position now Bishop before
developing a piece and just returning
this knight on c6 not bothering to save
it and give wider you to Center D takes
is 690 XE 4 and we can see that yeah
black gets active in the center
immediately the return of the material
yeah has some benefits as you get nice
development 24 attacks both afford
before and now the move Queen e7 which
covers all and threatens my Texas
recheck so why it needs to cover the
e-file and then for instance just taking
on c3 and Bishop d6 and black is
slightly better in this position
I forgot it better and I don't know
maybe it's even more than slightly
better black get you get some a solid
pawn structure and also has got the idea
of Bishop e5 which also comes into play
if y dares to capture on g7 so this is a
simple solution to
somewhat crazy gambit the best oops
maybe the the most ambitious way to play
this is not g6 just to show it briefly v
return back Bishop c4 and now we can see
that black has in fact slight
development issues and the best move
here is d5 immediately returning one
pawn and get the development going for
some for some 10 beam or gain some Tempe
to get the development going that's a
better expression so here a tempo on the
bishop and now Queen d7 and black
untangled CS pieces and has got an extra
piece for two pawns this is maybe the
cleanest way to play this but it's still
somewhat complicated so a simple
solution has mentioned is to return the
piece on on c6 this is this line and you
you will just get a fine position
without any any huge problems um White
has got some really rare moves here but
they are sometimes played a3 is some is
a move it's a quite quite strange
it just gives up a tempo but it's
sometimes played the idea is to yeah set
a little trap if if black plays Bishop
c5 here oops
then this counter pseudo sacrifice is
quite interesting for white as in this
kind of position a black would like to
play Bishop before and he cannot here so
this is it's interesting for white but
black has multiple options you can go up
it should be seven which is a good move
or I would suggest simply to play d5
here and like at yeah kind of a
four-night Scotch reversed a3 is simply
pretty useless extra move um it's not a
really fearsome move a three but you
sometimes get this stuff they should be
too is I think even more harmless
you can just play d5 and and get this
position and here white doesn't have any
active possibilities you can just
continue developing this should be seven
castles or take on c3 Bishop d6 so it's
just fine development and nothing much
to worry about um the main museum of the
Musa Dagh most of plate as mentioned at
d4 and Bishop b5 but a move that is
played quite often very often by people
who don't really who didn't really study
the theory well and don't know that the
correct answer is Bishop c4 and yeah
this is even this is slide slide
inaccuracy at least because black has
the pseudo sacrifice on d4 Knight takes
e4 on e4 not e4 Knight takes e4 and this
leads to pretty easy play for black and
very often if white is not careful it
can even be better for black pretty
pretty pretty quickly
further mistake here would be to take on
f7 but it's not uncommon to to get this
and in Blitzer bullet games people
simply want to drag the King out on f7
but in fact like he already has a pretty
clear advantage after d5 because black
has a full center here a5 and d5 has got
two bishops and will gain time on the
Knights white can go to g3 after which
black even pushes on here with E for
Knight back there's no other square very
unlucky and then Bishop c5 and black
just develops really Queen f6 is a move
to consider next need to be careful
about Queen h5 check attacking the King
the check and d5 so need to be careful a
bit because the King needs one or two
moves to get into safety usual moves
would be rook afraid and King g8 and
black just is better
sometimes the check also comes here and
then you just drop back to g8 the king
is a bit boxed in at the moment but
there are no pieces led to take it and
on for instance d3 here like just plays
h6 and sends off the snide to the rim on
h3 like now has multiple good moves a
good one for instance is just taking
this and Queen f6 followed by Bishop d6
or Bishop c5 and rook f8 with pressure
on f2 and f3 the knight doesn't have a
natural protection on g2 so black is
already better here really better it's
close to close to collapsing the wide
position so taking on a7 really it's a
mistake but you get it surprisingly
often um a gambit idea his castles
actually and this you can just answer by
um by Knight f6 if you want just return
and also return the pawn with a pretty
equal position it's a bit dull but black
is fine ideas his six and d5 took to
follow and blunt this bishop on c4 the
knight on c3 also isn't very well placed
after move like c6 and d5 also black
could could take here and play Bishop e7
which is also also fine 25 wins back the
porn but black develops freely so just
return the pawn on this gambit if it
should occur very very rare though um
yeah Knight takes e4 of course just
capturing is the most common move and
then play black plays d5 Bishop d3 and
here black has actually two options
funny enough the main move and the one I
would recommend for just simple persons
simplicity and it's just taking on e4 in
a recent book by grandmas Alaric Hoffman
the Hoffman repertoire also did a book
review on that he actually states that
this is strictly to a slight advantage
for white and he recommends instead the
funny move Knight to B form as being
equal I had a short look at this and
this move yeah seems to be fine it's
also you can also check this with a
computer and see that black
yeah gets this piece back anyway um it's
quite it's quite funny this move um if
you are interested you can have a look
at this and play this maybe to shock
your opponent even more but the simple
approach is still to take and I'm not
quite convinced that in this kind of
position his his castles castles rook e1
and p8 and then I think III and this he
assesses a slightly better for white I'm
not sure I think it's pretty much equal
maybe white has a slight advantage hard
to tell but it's nothing to worry about
really black has got a good development
no bad pieces so it shouldn't be
anything anything special for white but
okay if you think this is a bit too - I
don't know - borrowing or whatever then
you can check out this night before move
it's really funny funny move also I
found that this move is even a
possibility but the simple approach is
taking only form and you okay um yeah
this is Bishop c4 it's actually not
uncommon to get this and it's a good
chipper also for for junior players
often the white the white players some
so younger players with and younger
players that maybe know this line from
from the trainer's the coaches showing
them that this is a decent way to
develop your pieces then it's a good
good idea to play a ninety four and
immediately get some play going instead
of just copying everything and yeah this
is not the most inspiring position it's
no problem at all for black I think if
you are played the Italian game which we
will look at later then it's I think
almost unavoidable to to play this
position red it's no big deal but taking
only force I think just the better
angles and comparison okay these have
been the somewhat rarer moves so now off
to Bishop b5 yeah this should be five is
slightly I must admit annoying line for
black and in a particular respect it is
quite annoying for black if you are
trying to play for win because there are
some lines which are very very boring so
it's useful to know a line for black
here to get a little bit of
complications going and allow you to
play for win I will just show briefly
which lines are the problematic ones in
regards to draw just to briefly show
also the alternatives the most
interesting move actually in this
position and also the one you would like
to play it's 94 not my choice I'll show
my choice later but the problem the
slight practical problem with the
smoothness that white has got the very
boring option to take on d4 here if
white plays one of the main moves we
should a four or a Bishop c4 then black
can get very interesting a gambit play
with c5 sacrificing and Bishop c5
sacrificing the five pawn this is very
interesting for black and also yeah
needs to really really cool active
active play but yeah the slight issue is
white can capture here black takes e5
and now this Knight doesn't have any
Square to go so black needs to take here
captures here and now black could win
upon our d2 but this is very dangerous
as White's development advantage em yeah
gets to gets too alarming so you need to
take here and now why it takes here and
it's indeed quite difficult to play for
win here white will just exchange even
more pieces of play Bishop d3 Bishop III
the e-file is open and those bishops are
pretty aesthetic in this position you
cannot really do much it's of course
nothing to really worry about in terms
of ya getting problems or anything it's
just okay from like but it's just not
the position you you want if you if you
need to win a game so it's fine against
a good player who you will know that you
will play for win and play something
complicated but it's it's it's really
annoying if you expect your opponent to
take him on d4 another possibility is
Bishop before this is also very boring
in case white takes here which leads to
a position like this and you know no you
should somewhere and this is also very
draw
you've got opposite colored bishops a
complete symmetrical completely
symmetrical pawn structure and not much
to play for c7 also as an issue here you
cannot easily play Queen f6 or something
the swords are very boring so yeah what
what can you do after Bishop b5 to get
some interesting play going at the end I
went for Bishop c5 p.m. another
alternative which can be recommended to
maybe somewhat stronger players who know
what kind of risk they're able to take
Bishop d6 which looks yeah somewhat
weird of course because it blocks the c8
Bishop this move was playable though
like intends to castle Ruki aids Bishop
f8 back in at the end also something you
could look at okay but I went for Bishop
c5 this is also the recommendation and
already mentioned book by a master
Kaufman I always thought that this move
would be problematic for black but he
showed some lines in this book and
checked them and I think like is really
okay so at the end this is my
recommendation the problem with the
smoothness actually and that white has
got the opportunity to yeah to sacrifice
only five just like black sacrificed on
e4 after the Bishop c4 move so a black
takes d4 56 and now white um in order to
yeah plain viciously goes for her form
if you just recaptures here then the
position is quite similar to the Bishop
c4 94 line just with reversed colors
White has got the extra move it should
be five it's questionable though that
the bishop really is doing something
they are very often white will yeah just
drop this Bishop back to d3 and you got
exactly the same position just with
Calais reversed quite funny um
I think as already mentioned I think
this is pretty equal so nothing to worry
about the more ambitious move after
Bishop d6 here is f4 and yeah here black
needs to know what he's doing especially
where to drop the night the best square
c6 year and now white go c5 in
to get the porn back after all the piece
back after all it should be for now
securing the bishop and now wide scraps
on f6 he cannot delay this forever and
now you recapture and I think yeah Black
has a pretty good position here I think
those pawn moves f4 and deform don't
really yeah
fit fit together - well a possible
continuation here is Bishop b3 after
this black should play d5 let's say
castles takes on c3 and Bishop f5 and
this also highlights why those pawns FY
and d4 don't really harmonize so well
because if is a very weak Square and
black immediately dropped this Bishop to
the square or tries to go to this Square
and I think black is maybe already more
than equal but so I think I would prefer
black here um this is just a great
square only form another possibility
would be UPS instead of Bishop e3
a3 after which you got a choice you can
capture still or bash Bishop f5 is also
playable just capture and d5 is fine
though
it's a bit different because white now
also have the chance to play at five and
this is the difference to the to the
line before still I think black and
doesn't have any any big big problems
also as mentioned Bishop a5 is a plan
here this kind of position I think you
can you can simply play you don't need
to learn long variations so this would
be 95 is basically fine so the
alternative is castles and black also
just castles um here
White has multiple options but the only
really testing one is still the
sacrifice as
was quite simulus just with both sides
castling moves inserted but just quickly
before we go 295 of the alternatives one
alternative here's Bishop c6 this is six
and now white is a choice you can play a
quiet move like d3 or you can capture
and this is quite an interesting
difference between Bishop c5 and Bishop
before in the bishop before line after
rook e8 white could play 93 which
attacked the bishop on before and the
bishop on before didn't really have much
alternative than just captured c3 in
otherwise your just porn down but here
black has has alternatives he can drop
this bishop to deform there's one
possibility simply blocking a white's
development also Bishop g4 is
interesting which leaves right with the
only move Queen e1 quite ugly and then
Bishop d4 and white has got some
problems to really get his development
going if I was under pressure I cannot
kick the g3 g4 a bishop with f3 as this
pawn is pinned and on h3 you just
dropped the bishop back to to h5 or
maybe even Bishop d7 and earlier c5
Bishop c6 to come so black has quite
interesting pressure here for this pawn
it's not a dead drawn position or
anything so this is much more fighting
than in the bishop before line if white
plays it slow and just develops with d3
you should take the chance to play
Bishop g4 this is quite strong I think
h3 Bishop h5 and in this position we've
set a little trap if white wants to kick
this Bishop you can really sacrifice the
90m and white is in a very annoying pin
on the f3 Knight he doesn't have a
bishop anymore that could break the spin
on e2
protect the night on g2 so is completely
in the spin just protecting protecting
the night with the Queen so a line like
Bishop III Bishop d6 king g2 to protect
the night f5 is super dangerous
for instance Queenie 1:27 Knight h2 and
their form and black ass and I think a
decisive attack already
so it's a useful idea to remember this
kind of sacrifice especially if Y does
so yeah a little place to to get rid of
this pin black really is clearly better
here um so white might prepare g4 with
Bishop g5 after which you can just go
here and now White has an alternative he
can give you the complete bishop pair
which is fine of course or I could drop
back here after which for instance g5
Bishop g3 97 is very fine for black here
black actually um has got a positional
threat Queen f6 and Queen f6 would
further damage the pawn structure and
killed this Bishop on g3 this is classic
theme in in open games let's say Queen
e2 just for instance Queen your six rook
t1 and now this kind of this kind of
structure this is very useful to
remember this was first shown by my
watch champion kappa blanka in a classic
game i think against winter winters the
most the white player and the problem is
that the bishop on g3 is just a dead
piece and it will never move anywhere
because of this sick double porn he
cannot activate this bishop it's
basically a piece down so black is very
funny it's a useful pattern to remember
um so what else is there after rook e8
after capturing here okay Dwight can
also drop back to f3 I forgot that then
you can just get the pawn back and
you've got the bishop pair in an open
position so all yeah all fine too to get
to get a good game what else is there d3
t3 you can white can play d3 just try to
develop the c1 Bishop after this you can
go rukiye 8 and just develop further
one interesting moopheus also 94 the
idea is that the pawn grab here is
punished here but d6 93 Bishop g4 and
white gets ugly and ugly poor
information on the King side a possible
continuation would be would be this year
first taking the bishop back and then
Knight h5 and Queen h4 black has a nice
attack here and no problems at all look
she want Queen Queen h3 for instance and
an f3 is a huge problem
why does I think for us to return
material here already so 94 is a good
option if why'd you capture captures
here you can recapture with the bishop
with the pawn you can also take but this
is just simpler and now black easily
continues developing with c6 possibly
with d5 would be the ambitious way are
just c6 d6 and getting the bishop out
it's very useful to remember that
exchanging this knight on c6 against the
knight on f3 is very often useful for
black there are almost no cases where
this kind of exchange would be harmful
the point being that the knight on c6 is
not the greatest piece ever it's not
doing so much especially if white later
on
place c3 at some point let's say 92 and
c3 then the knight doesn't have any huge
yeah further future prospects if black
exchanges this he also is able to use
the CND pod freely see 65 or 66 or so
the data for is a nice active
alternative especially as the porn grab
leads to attractive plane this is
already a quite rare position though so
95 is is the critical move black
recaptures deform Bishop d6 and f4
otherwise it's just not enough to to get
something white could take again and
this would transpose to the mentioned
line above when white took on e5 on move
5 so Bishop d3 gyro p8 and yeah the same
pretty equal position that we had before
so um again f4 is the move to go and now
it's useful you need to remember here
that Knight g4 son the correct move and
the idea will become obvious later he 5
the main move also possible especially
to we're treating the the bishop on b5
and attacking in the night then here's
should just give the material back with
a bishop before Bishop takes takes on c3
BC 394 Bishop e3 d5 and black is very
fine he's got this whole if only for
again to to play with an ideal scenario
would be something like Bishop f5 96 we
should be for getting both pieces to
control a form very nice so black has no
huge problems so if v is the main move
and then your just retreat to e7 after
which white can try B should be - or h3
it leads to somewhat similar positions
h3 and now important d6 you returned the
piece if white takes on g4
you can recapture with the night there
should be two and then h5 and sorry this
kind of setup is some young somewhat
risky for white as the knight on d4 is
the constant worry ideas like twin to h4
can be really powerful so I don't think
this that h3 takes g4 is really a good
idea so takes on f6
is the safer option and then black
recaptures this is the idea also y94 was
the move here because you want to get
the chance to recapture on f6 with a
knight and now a possible continuation
would be g4 very aggressive g5 Bishop d3
c6 black just is very solid and he has
ideas to play on this Foursquare later
let's say Carina three Queen b6 a3 of
course black cannot take on d4 now
because of they should be three but a
good plan hands and the plan to remember
is 90 98 we should be three at f5
blocking this this F pawn and getting
the knight on d6 and then on e4 next
smooth and black is fine if I was just
great Square to to use and why does
still lots of moves away from getting a
Knight to e5 himself so black is very
very okay here yeah what else
white can go Bishop e2 and this is very
similar you go to six
and this way returned the piece f5
trying to use the bishop on c1 and also
avoiding this somewhat rigid f4d for
structure d5 now we should be 5 rupee
8:23 and now important to set up c3
rookie a 1 and then B five black gains
based on the queenside and it has a very
solid position in the center and on on
his King side white won't get any attack
going or anything
and this b5 move also might allow to
push the knight back from c3 and further
play on getting this you for square also
just a5 Bishop a6 and before might be an
idea so I don't see any huge problems
for black and it's still a fighting
position maybe it's around equal but
certainly nothing you need to be afraid
of and it's easily imaginable that you
can also win games from this position
it's not not really a dry sort of a firm
so this was the four Knights it's not
not so much or theory it's not a very
you know theoretically demanding opening
for black you just need to be aware of
them the mentioned draws lines if you
need to win to to avoid them so I'm
recap briefly here on d3 we had to d5
and the transposition to the Vienna game
line from rising from move to Knight c3
and three g3 just the transposition we
had the slow moves a3 and there should
be two after which you can go d5 on
Bishop c4 you need to remember this yeah
the sudo sacrifice IAM getting
the piece back quickly and also setting
the trap for why to take here which is
really bad yeah there was the crazy 995
they had a wind gambit after which the
simplest continuation was this one
returning the piece and getting active
play in the center um after Bishop b5
being the main move here recommendation
was Bishop c5 and then you need to take
a look mostly at this forked reclines
line or oops the same fair after both
players have Castle also 95 here is the
critical the critical move what you need
to remember is that especially here 94
is the right move to to allow the
Knights to retake on f6 and this gives
black and harmonious setup yeah the four
Knights not too dangerous but sometimes
quite boring if you yeah if you're not
careful with selecting your line if you
don't mind draw really on a very stair
position then my recommendation here
after but should be faithful to be 94
it's really leads to a fascinating
fascinating play if Y doesn't go for
this line but it's it's simply something
you need to consider if you don't mind
this 94 is a great move and very
interesting to study you know this um
what's the four Knights game
oh I'm not quite sure I think the next
video will be about the scotch and this
also will include um I think this this
line as it can easily transpose yeah
thanks for watching I hope you enjoyed
the video and yeah talk to you soon with
the next part of the series or maybe in
some other video I'm not quite sure talk
to you soon of course